A long time ago in a small midwest town, an
intrepid hero named Kevin Bacon taught a whole
town how-ta cut loose… and kick off their
Sunday shoes.
But, did he actually make a difference in
their love lives?
Hey dancing queens, young and sweet thanks
for tuning into DNews.
I'm Mixmaster Trace and this one is for all
you lovers out there.
Movies, music videos, even classic Jane Austen
stories all imply dance is essential for two
people to have cake by the ocean.
But is this for real?
Did dance evolve to be part of our mating
rituals?
Lots of animals use courtship displays and
dances to attract mates.
Some scientists argue if you look at hunter-gatherer
societies you'd see dancing associated with
fitness and sexiness.
But that being said dancing is rare in the
animal world, scientifically speaking.
By science's definition, dancing has to do
with synchronizing movements to a beat; it
can't be a trained behavior, it has to be
spontaneous!
When Willy and the Poorboys are playin', you
bring a nickel and tap your feet.
No one told to do that, you just… do!
And humans are in a small club of animals
that can do this.
According to a study in Frontiers in Systems
Neuroscience and a couple pieces in Current
Biology, only species which can practice vocal
imitation can learn to dance!
So, that includes some species of parrot,
some cockatoos, the California sea lion, and
Asian elephants… among others.
All these animals can imitate and have all
been observed "dancing" to a beat.
Not well… but they can.
Humans on the other hand, we're the dancing
machines of the animal kingdom!
You might think Peter, you suck, but trust
me, you can dance.
You're 9 Ladies Dancing and 10 Lords-a-Leaping
above animals … they are the loneliest number.
And that's good, according to a study in Evolution
of Human Behavior, when humans synchronize
our motions, it raises our pain threshold
by releasing endorphins -- feel good brain
chemicals -- and this also encourages social
closeness!
This happens even without music… other research
has been done with rowing teams!
And a study from Plos Genetics even identified
two genes associated with creative dancing
and paired that with a need for social communication!
But, just because you have a chance do your
dance at the Space Jam, doesn't mean something
happened and you're head over heels, or that
you're an MF Starboy, amirite?
Or put another way, dancing doesn't automatically
equal romancing…
Music plays a big part too.
Tons of studies show listening to music triggers
a flood of reward chemicals in the brain -- making
us feel happy!
And when it comes to mating, "music," argues
author Daniel Levitin, "would insinuate itself
into the mind of a potential mate."
implying this sick beat turns into a sexual
earworm…
So, putting all this together: music makes
us feel good, synching behaviors makes us
feel good and adds social closeness, and dancing
is associated with sexiness and fitness…
It seems like dancing to the music is a pleasure
double-whammy!
If you can do that, you're well on your way
to the bedroom hymns.
The problem here is no one knows why dancing
makes us feel this way, we just know it does.
Hopefully, we do more research on this because
Please tell me something, I need answers man,
I wish there was a "more research is needed
song…"
Special thanks to Kay Jewelers for sponsoring
this episode.
For 100 Years, Every Kiss Begins With Kay.
All dancing and mating aside, do animals even
like music?
Find out here.
How many song lyrics did you hear in this
video?
List them in the comments.
Make sure you subscribe and if the sun refused
to shine, I would still be loving you.
Thanks for watching.